[Music]
happy holidays everyone
this time of celebration comes once a
year so do our awesome new holiday items
of course you made sure to be good all
year round
make sure you save some bucks to get
yourself the gift
that you most surely deserve make it to
the top of the leaderboards and you'll
get some gold
frankincense and mirror or their in-game
equivalent
and may your winter be as fun as winter
can be
[Music]
i need some good memes today some
qualitative stuff some [ __ ] to make me
wake up let's go leave your memes on the
reddit 19 year old
now measure your peeps in the next
episode
don't mind me just trying to surprise my
girlfriend in next lawyer
hannah will you marry me what
no this is real proof or bad
yes she loves to watch
felix videos with me so i hope this
works
i love this there's so much just so good
about this
the bathroom selfie the sweatpants
hell yeah hannah you got yourself a
catch kinda if you don't say yes
then that means you said no and that
sucks come on
we need an update even if it's a yes or
no we need an update
this is so weird i love it amazing
that's a first we've seen prom we've
seen people ask out but we never seen a
marriage proposal
dad how did you propose to mom i made a
public post and the most follower
created subreddit
hoping he would review it in his online
show sweetie
the podcast were flying through the chat
while fellow 19 year olds i put it so i
could
propose nice very nice
yeah i i takes balls i'll give a big pp
we made pewds some armor in four days
hope you like it
oh whoa
oh dude it's got the tambourine
god damn
oh we lit up
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah see how we made it
cosplay shop select style guys
huge shout out that looked nuts good
sense of style too i love it
four days y'all did everyone dirty
even the detail on the neck that's so
cool god damn
well done i i was just like oh make uh
something cool
hey speaking of which i got another
challenge for you guys
yeah y'all know tuber simulator the
greatest game of all time
what the [ __ ] is this now they told me
we can put
anything in this game and that i can
draw it
this looks so [ __ ] it's supposed to be a
tambourine
okay i'm committing pewdiepie tambo it
looks like
someone's brain or liver or i don't i
don't know what
if you've been looking for something to
put on your gravestone now's your chance
50 by 50 pixels submit to the y
and i'll pick the best one or once and
they will be mortalized in the greatest
game of all time
pewdiepie tuber simulator just a small
note as well
i've been spamming this game in your
face for so long but i haven't really
spoken about
it and the thing is the game came out
was it 2017
or it's been a while but automates have
been constantly updating it
and comparing it now what the game is
now
to comparing what it was when we release
it you know it's day and night
it's got so many updates so many cool
things to it so if you haven't
you know checked it out in a while it's
a great time to get back in
i highly recommend it it's a super fun
game who matches their tie with their
shirt that's so cringe are you kidding
me
are you serious 50 000
yeah and i look hella popping dude i
look good
okay yeah i'm cringe we know this guy
god damn it i say one thing one offhand
remark during a live stream and i get
memed on by the subreddit this is not
fair this time i drew martin's sixth art
style
my style cool finn is a verb hey gravity
falls
adventure time avatar i love the avatar
one that's great
felix art style why is she so good at my
art style
the avatar one is amazing yeah up for
that [ __ ]
oh it's quan i got it is this like
instead of the minecraft one i mean
that's impressive
okay joel have you told your story on
your channel about
when you used to steal [ __ ] you have
right next
yes i broke into this youtuber's house i
don't know he had 100 million subs or
something it was in japan no one was
there
i i thought it was the perfect i don't
steal
just for the record it was in a video
game
so it doesn't count okay what have we
got
i already see it oh
do you do you see it hey all right
what the [ __ ]
see whenever i do this the bullets just
disappear and i'm like
this that's beautiful big people right
there
no no
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] makes fun of me for
using baby cam
bro you gotta use a mouthpiece oh that's
why it doesn't work
oh my god it took us so long to realize
guys get this to jj acet that's why he
can't play it oh my god well he's
probably can't play it anyway
sorry but i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i knew this
because they offered hey do you want to
buy the mouthpiece
i'm like no i think it comes with it i
don't know why i need it but i assume
to be fair it comes in this massive
freaking package it's easy to miss it
yeah you're gonna have to dish out 20
bucks uh to buy that now
because i assume you threw away the
package
[Laughter]
that's annoying oh you have cut your
hair you are beautiful
thanks
yeah that's 100 it's targeted harassment
that's a good one pewdiepie who's been
in law 145 times
damn this pretty pie guy is popular
adam warlock707 who has been in the 1810
what the [ __ ] is adam warlock some
underground
legend oh he did this one i remember
this that was a great one
everyone always have people who makes
bad memes but no one appreciate people
make good memes
thank you thank you adam yeah hey
another fan i made for pizz yeah i see
it that's amazing god damn how old are
you
so talented that's nuts there's not a
question he's nine years old i am 19.
he's 19 years old everyone can see it
pewdiepie cake has it happened at last
sometimes you guys ask me in the comment
section if i can do so and so cake
and a lot of these cakes that i make are
for orders
but sometimes i'll have some extra
batter and then i'll decide
let's see what to maybe have fun with
this week if it's not too
difficult on my last cocoa melon cake i
noticed
something she made a coconut again no
no or a pewdiepie cake i didn't really
know who he was i knew my son watched
him as well as my dog
that's really great that we have a super
hardcore fan here for the
so i had to google him to see who he was
and i know he's that
i knew that he was this famous youtuber
it was a time yes
okay between this and grey's anatomy to
be honest but there was a lot of spray
painting
let's just go with that there's not many
options in terms of design so i decided
to do his logo
the red background with the squiggles as
well as the main logo for him
and this is the end product that i came
up with i don't know if he has tick tock
but is there someone we can tag possibly
[Laughter]
all right yeah sure that's cool hey
speaking of tick tock apparently there's
some lady i'm not on tick tock
i don't follow tick tock there's someone
that's getting like 100 000 followers is
that it no 100 million sorry
and everyone i've been seeing some
comments being like oh she can't take i
don't care
good for her okay i'm not trying to
create let's focus on the real target
here
nursery rhyme channels all right just
don't be toxic i don't care okay
great it's all to me it's all a joke
except nursery
rhyme channels that needs to burn pewds
return to minecraft
sven yes my master is back pewter starts
a new world sven
spencer i'll be back
i'll be back this sucks all i got is
signs of a sociopath well it can't be me
aggression
risk taking me
responsibility manipulativeness
hey i said that word right first try
yeah
negligible first try hell yeah
i'm so scared
[Laughter]
yeah it's working
[Music]
well i'm glad the two-year-olds are
entertained at least
pewdiepie comedy for infants i love it a
man of culture
is that person is going to grow up to be
big peepee
right there hell yeah man i always
cheers me up it's so good
honey bee bumble bee
no that's not how you spell it what the
[ __ ] he's gonna be so pissed
19 year old pewdiepie can you please
bring marchand one more time in your
videos we missed her
but yeah basically i can do this chick
what's it
hell yeah minecraft hardcore the it's
really fun so far i really like it i i'm
gonna play right after this
i'm sorry but pewdiepie's expression
when he got time it was too perfect
yeah because i break the rules don't dig
straight there
y'all don't know you could learn from a
bike minecraft viking
veteran yeah sure that's what i meant to
say and this is why we don't take
candies from strangers kids
come with me now freak unless they're
swedish you could always rely on a
swedish person
trust me this
[ __ ] thumbnail guy every time
that actually looks legit what the hell
keanu reeves made a shame which
this is so awesome all right so that's
my house
and it
now house is beautiful
it would never flip me off it's
contemporary
he keeps don't get it look at him he's
terrified
he buzzes happily are you sure wait what
he likes me likes me oh my
god i didn't know you could know that
it's a cute little bunny my only friend
the bunny
no no don't
no now i feel bad
underrated pose what the hell that's so
cute
i've been terrorizing buddies left and
right it's amazing
i have to terrorize them more know your
place bunny
i don't care if you subscribed or not
you need to teach him
the harshness of life let your bunny see
it so they know
what's like to expected of them i hold
him back
run i can't believe this got a fata
that's so awesome
if you know you know oh another child
run your little fools run
run oh you're sad
well he said damn they're fast jesus
come back yeah
oh i know because i i know pewdiepie's
videos it's crazy
i guess you could say i'm a fan
he comes from the trees he's french with
the bees
he comes from the trees he's friends
with the bee
it comes from the trees oh
uh they don't know i made the pee pee
pie upload button on pewdiepie's
submissions
did you really i made the pdp [ __ ]
people
that deserves an upvote they just don't
know who is it
not rotten legend put out on your
gravestone
then they'll know then they'll know bro
there's not even a pee pee button what
are you talking about
how pierce treats his fans during
streams happy streets his fans during a
video
yeah i'm a little hostile in the stream
i apologize
to get into the story you must you must
really immerse yourself in the game
felix your settings are wrong you need
to change the dssf but settings in the
thing and maybe show you that but
live streams was a mistake maybe maybe i
shouldn't do live
walkthroughs lives or playthroughs like
it's fun to share with you guys but also
yeah it does take me out of the game a
little bit
or maybe i shouldn't read chat so much i
don't know
[Applause]
because when you're playing alone yeah
you immerse yourself more
and i can cut out a lot of the stupid
[ __ ] i do that
people aren't normally supposed to see
just how dumb i am
this is an amazing panel god damn huge
pp
oh it's matrix oh thank you pewter's
parent at age 30. let's have baby
yes pewds exit 30.
oh god where the
what am i doing i can't what the [ __ ]
top 10 photos taken before terrible
disaster that was so funny
and so annoying during lockdown yeah
yeah yeah
i posted about this on my instagram we
affected the economy during lock them in
the uk tambourine section is also
rocketed by 40
i wonder why i think i read something
that
tambourines were sold more than xbox and
playstations
mom can i have a tambourine for
christmas
so i can have big peepee what do peon's
name is b again
me see that's how you spell it
sheesh you always get it wrong i don't
know how you
to dumb you mighty diamonds with the
stone well it's gold it's gold it's gold
it doesn't no no skip skip skip
trying again for the mice check your
whatsapp award icon
okay okay nice
yeah that should be official it's
already official nice
there it goes well done well done you've
earned it
my parents with nineteen let's marry yes
me with nineteen
i gotta watch your thirty-year-old
swedish man playing minecraft with his
pit people
okay this is good now now i don't feel
so we're equally pathetic
okay i'll allow that bro don't get mad
at 19. that's too young
you're not you can't make life choices
at that age
hello felix i am also a minecraft
veteran
and i just wanted to let you know that
you can also have five
and even say no you need to pay me now
my lawyers will be cut
[Music]
getting six diamonds in the first
episodes try to mine cold with a stuffed
god damn it i'm a micro veteran treat me
with
respect god damn it yo
[ __ ] paint dude god
damn hell yeah that's almost as good as
my tambourine
yo this is your chance submit to the
pewdiepie
tuber simulator competition i'll be
expecting them
when you had a bad day your music saved
me you're welcome
man this is so fun i love the why you
guys always put me in a good mood
y'all the best i appreciate you thank
you now look at griff
have you looked i feel like i say tell
people to look and they don't look and i
don't get it
i feel like i'm going through a weird
time lately where i don't really know
what i'm doing on youtube
anymore i'm doing like playthroughs but
people just seem to get annoyed by it
and i'm just like
am i too old for youtube now what's
happening maybe i'll bring back book
reviews or something so i feel like i'm
part of my age sven a creeper failed to
20 world backups
nope that's a lie i never i never
cheated sven
it's the og sven anyway thanks for
watching
thanks for all the support i really
really do appreciate it and
i'll see you guys tomorrow with another
minecraft yeah
yeah profess
yes huge thank you to everyone for
supporting the arcade indiegogo campaign
it was a huge success to say the least
look at this thing
it's beautiful now as a popular demand
this thing now works with pc games top
pc games
i'm talking call of duty doom
gotta try this baby on doom pub g
valorent
you name me okay we don't have every
game but a ton of games
so the blaster now works with geforce
now which is very cool
it also works with pc it has a ton of
library of android games
it's is a new way to play we're bringing
it to you so
the product is now available at
arcade.games
the website itself is very cool check it
out
honestly but you also get ten dollars
off if you enter the code
pewdiepie to get one of these bad boys
so yeah link is in the description
check it out